>> WELCOME TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY" AND
HAPPY PASSOVER AND GOOD FRIDAY.
I AM TAMMY BRUCE IN FOR SEAN.
TONIGHT, WE ARE AT THE BITTER
END OF YET ANOTHER TERRIBLE WEEK
FOR JOE BIDEN.
DREADFUL ECONOMIC NEWS.
THE MAYHEM AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
AND PULL NUMBERS LOWER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
NOT ONLY IS BIDEN UNDERWATER BY
DOUBLE DIGITS IN FIVE NEW POLLS,
BUT HE IS ALSO STRUGGLING INTO
KEY DEMOGRAPHICS THAT DEMOCRATS
DESPERATELY NEED TO WIN MY
COLLECTIONS.
ACCORDING TO QUINNIPIAC, ONLY
26% OF HISPANICS NOW APPROVE OF
BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND GALLUP FOUND THAT BIDEN IS
ALSO HEMORRHAGING SUPPORT AMONG
YOUNG VOTERS.
ONLY 39% OF GENERATION Z AND 41%
OF MILLENNIALS APPROVE OF DOOR
BIDEN.
TONIGHT, PULL NUMBERS ARE JUST
THE BEGINNING OF BIDEN'S
PROBLEM.
PRESIDENT BIDEN LOOKED LOST AND
CONFUSED AND AT ONE POINT HE
ATTEMPTED TO SHAKE HANDS WITH
SOMEONE WHO WASN'T THERE.
AND DURING A SPEECH, JOE BIDEN
CLAIMED THAT HE USED TO BE A
FULL PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA.
WATCH THIS.
>> I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED.
I'VE BEEN ON A LOT OF UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES.
THIS IS REALLY AN IMPRESSIVE
PLACE.
>> Tammy: YEAH, THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
HOWEVER AT ONE POINT THE
UNIVERSITY DID PAY BIDEN ALMOST